aquí hemos escrito dos propiedades
importantes de las integrales
indefinidas y en el futuro veremos que
son muy útiles lo que esto nos dice es
que la integral indefinida de la suma de
dos funciones diferentes es igual a la
suma de la integral indefinida de cada
una de las funciones por separado esto
otro nos dice que la integral indefinida
de una constante esto no es una función
de x que multiplica a efe x es igual a
esa constante que multiplica a la
integral indefinida de fx podemos ver
esto como que sacamos la constante de la
integral en próximos vídeos veremos que
los dos son muy útiles si ustedes están
de acuerdo con lo que está aquí escrito
está bien pero si quieren comprobarlo
pueden calcular la derivada de ambos
lados de la igualdad y usar las
propiedades de las derivadas para
mostrar que sus derivadas son iguales
vamos a hacerlo lo que voy a hacer aquí
para argumentar que esto es verdadero es
usar las propiedades de las derivadas y
aplicarlas en ambos lados para
y mostrar que la cualidad se mantiene
cuando nos deshacemos de ambas
integrales calculemos la derivada con
respecto a x de este lado y de este otro
lado del lado izquierdo nos queda lo que
está dentro de la integral indefinida
efe x + gx a que será igual el lado
derecho
veamos nuestras propiedades de las
derivadas la derivada de la suma de dos
términos es lo mismo que la suma de las
derivadas de cada término así que
tenemos la derivada con respecto a x de
este primer término más la derivada con
respecto a x de este segundo término
esta primera parte es la integral de fx
de x más esta otra parte es la integral
de gx de x akiba fx y acaba de x aquí
será igual esto ponemos los signos de
igual y la derivada de esto con respecto
a x va a ser f x y la derivada de esto
otro con respecto a x es gd x
es verdadero ahora veamos esta otra
propiedad hagamos lo mismo calculemos la
derivada en ambos lados la derivada con
respecto a x de esto y la derivada con
respecto a x de esto otro del lado
izquierdo claramente nos queda c por fx
en el lado derecho aplicamos las
propiedades de las derivadas y sabemos
que la derivada de una constante por
algo es lo mismo que la constante por la
derivada de ese algo así que tenemos la
derivada con respecto a x de la integral
indefinida de fx de x todo esto va a ser
igual a c por fx nuevamente pueden ver
que la cualidad se mantiene
espero que con esto ustedes se convenzan
de que las propiedades son verdaderas
pero lo más importante es saber cuándo
aplicarlas por ejemplo si tengo la
integral indefinida de x cuadrada +
coseno de x podemos decir que esto es lo
mismo que la integral indefinida de x al
cuadrado de x más la integral indefinida
de coseno de x
escribimos esto y escribimos esto otro
de manera que podemos evaluarlos por
separado esto otro es útil porque si
queremos encontrar la integral de pi por
seno de x de x podemos quitar esta
constante de la integral porque no
depende de x y se va a mantener igual
esto va a ser igual a pi por la integral
de seno de x de x son dos propiedades
muy útiles y con esto terminamos